you going to out he was dismissed as
yesterday's man yet former Prime
Minister David Cameron walked into
number 10 Downing Street in his new role
as foreign secretary for Tuesday's
cabinet meeting we build Partnerships
with our friends we deter our enemies
and we keep our country strong that's
why I'm doing the job and I'm delighted
to accept he may not be a new face at
the table but it is a new position for
the man who left his mark on the UK by
enabling its exit from the European
Union it was Cameron who called the
referendum on brexit we have to ensure
that the conservative party reflects the
changes the country has faced reflects
uh the issues that affect people today
that's exactly what the prime minister's
concentrating on now he is a cabinet of
experience but also younger people with
new ideas as well coming into it prime
minister Rishi Sak's cabinet reshuffling
may have not as come as a complete
surprise especially after comments made
by the previous Home Secretary SU braan
whose hawkish style angered many within
the conservative party and after a week
where she called homelessness a
lifestyle Choice dubbed London rallies
for ceasefire in Gaza as hate marches
and denounced police forces as biased it
was clear something had to give while
David Cameron may have his own baggage
to contend with his place in the cabinet
would indicate that the Prime Minister
has a more Centrist approach to politics
in mind especially when it comes to
foreign forign
policy the challenge facing Cameron now
will be how to navigate sunak foreign
policy at a time of escalating tensions
where diplomacy will be key to finding a
resolution Sonia Gago Al jazer
London